hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I'm Geo I'm Bart
and let me just Clear My Throat real
quick how come you always have phlegm I
don't know right when we're about to
record because I think what's happening
is I'm talking more and more where like
the whole morning like the whole morning
I'm not like talking to anyone so my
vocal cords are just chilling and maybe
they're just like
some [ __ ] popping in there that's like
sleeping and then as soon as they my
vocal cords start vibrating it's like Yi
and then all the phlegm comes up I don't
know why do you need to start doing the
Asian Dad thing
yeah in the morning every Asian dad is
[Applause]
gonna get all of it out and I even hear
my mom doing it yeah like in the morning
I hear like through her bathroom through
like four sets of walls
but at least
she's a professional podcaster unless
someone I know she's really good I know
and I'm I'm sure like my coffee has
dairy in it so I'm sure Dairy is
probably causing some [ __ ] why would you
do something like that well it's
powdered I didn't really think about it
until after where I was like well I need
the coffee because even when we did that
a voice acting lesson for JK back in the
day the voice acting coach was like no
coffee at all because it gives you uh
well thanks for sharing that tip you
didn't watch that video you producer oh
my God that's so irresponsible you watch
your own videos you're the producer you
need to watch it no I don't I'm not the
director you're not the editor you're in
control of making sure that product is
good and it is good it happened all
right all right that's it directly
because she said that um the coffee
saliva thick and then it goes uh what's
in your cup
matcha baby is it really take a look oh
it is well thanks for sharing that tip
you son of a [ __ ]
and speaking about Sons
um you've been we don't want to speak
about no [ __ ] sons you [ __ ] lying
sack of [ __ ] I am speaking about Sons
tone it down homeboy what's in that juby
cup holy [ __ ] it's the new ceremonial
matcha so I'm getting real ceremonial
opinion I'm saying yeah
um so speaking of sons we've been living
you've been like a sun sun like you've
been hitting the role of a son for like
a solid three weeks now your mom's been
staying with us going on three weeks and
prior to that we were both kind of like
at least I felt like we were both kind
of like I don't know your mom's kind of
a little too much you know but
considering everything that happened
with your pop what makes you feel like
that's too much because I got my own
feelings of why she's too much no um no
I'm going that's where my question's
going oh
um so because of everything that
happened with your pops like you know it
just brought our family closer together
can I tell you a comment
that I read that I was like dude that's
just so [ __ ] up it was also so [ __ ]
funny at the same time oh no
no but why are you all knowing already
because you're a comedian it's probably
gonna be really [ __ ] up if you think
the comments [ __ ] up but it's also
funny
okay
so I posted
um he had been showing my mom around
Vegas she loves it so much she don't
want to leave
and in the comic goes we all know where
this is going
and I was like damn
[Music]
fight too if you didn't get it you know
what I'm saying
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you so shout
out to that hater because I know he's a
hater
because I clicked on the account yeah no
posts of course yeah but
I recognize a genius line I recognize a
bar when I see a bar you know yeah shout
outs to you Mochi three four five was it
what would she three four five
yeah that's uh that's pretty gnarly
I was like come on my [ __ ] eyes are
on fire oh [ __ ]
oh my God I don't know where to take it
from here no um
yeah it's been it's been
um really cool you know you always hear
this
saying and that's what a lot of people I
think is their go-to condolence is like
oh man
your Pops passed away oh man like um you
know you know what's gonna happen it's
just gonna bring the family tighter
right and I go my parents are divorced
why would it ever bring the family
tighter they say that I've never heard
anyone be that positive yeah most people
are like oh you know it's usually me
saying [ __ ] like that oh maybe it's just
you yeah and like usually people don't
now most people do they do take it there
from what I've never heard that a lot of
I mean I only surround myself with like
positive uplifting people yeah they have
the same friends and they usually say
stuff like that they either go like they
used to go oh man like you know it
usually brings people together
and um I really doubted that statement
because I'm like what is there to bring
together they're already they're part
they're like separate worlds oh
literally just for your
circumstance my specific
because my parents it's not like you
know like uh I talked to my other one of
my other friends when his Pops passed
away he got really close with his mom
and they really leaned on each other
makes sense they're our family I've
never been a family with not only them
two because they were divorced but I had
my own
um distance with my dad because my dad
and my mom got divorced when I was six
and so I've always had more of an uncle
relationship because I only saw him like
a few times yeah a week and uh me and my
mom because she was so quite a bit by
the way a few times a week is quite a
bit I feel like you saw your dad more
than I saw my dad impossible
you guys I always have presents yeah you
come home his shoes are on the ground
his favorite cup I see that's true
there's something it's different when
you like when you you look at your
family picture
and it's you your mom and her dad yeah
and the dad's head is cut off really she
did that her [ __ ] eyes poked out she
really no no there was there was
something like that there was some where
it's like [ __ ] like I would look him
through the fold I mean it's fresh right
like a divorce I'm looking through photo
albums and [ __ ] just straight
beheadings on all the [ __ ] like four
bices isn't that a bummer when you have
such a good photo and then you have like
an ex-friend or just someone that did
you wrong or someone that you just don't
have a relationship with yeah you're
like [ __ ] man that was a good ass memory
and you want to keep the photo do you
throw the photo away or do you just cut
them out
I think it's funny when you know exactly
who that is oh just [ __ ] up their face
because it doesn't
have to do anything you know I mean like
it's like there's a bottle of like me
holding two hands and then this person's
head's cut off I'm like Mom I wonder who
this guy is
the president's at least I had it you
didn't
and so
um yeah so I didn't have that but even
with my mom being a super Asian tiger
mom I had my own distance with her yeah
so like growing up I never really felt
like I had parents and and I know you
probably remember when we first got
together
and we're like revealing our um after
the the sexual desires were Unleashed on
each other I didn't get
oh yeah I
real and
answer or not the answer
really understand but let me finish what
I was saying is after we released sexual
tensions on each other oh that's what
you wanted to finish that's what I
[ __ ] interrupted no but I was like
remember when I told you like
I don't think I would cry yeah that was
later in the relationship both of my
parents if both of my parents pass away
whether together or simultaneously
remember I told you I don't think I
would cry and I just don't like I would
look at all my friends in the
relationship they have with their
parents and
um I never had that you know uh where
you'd be like I'd be devastated if they
were gone we're just like all of my
friends and I think that's like the
majority of it probably represents
regular people
your parents are usually the people that
you feel very safe with of course and
they're the people that know your ugly
aside yeah and um
they'll judge you you could do no wrong
but you can do no wrong they'll judge it
but you can do no wrong and I never
felt that unconditional love from my
parents I don't know if because they're
too Asian or what the hell it was what
does that feel like not having
unconditional love
maybe it feels like it feels like you're
sleeping over at someone else's house
what yeah
I felt that before keep going like at
home with you
totally comfortable not really I make
you fart outside I mean it's sad that's
true I mean if I just call you a [ __ ]
and it feels good but it makes up for it
okay but like when whether you're home
or not it feels like it's my house right
I can walk around naked if I wanted to I
could pick my nose I could do whatever
the hell I want and I know that like
it's a safe space
ever since I was a kid living with my
mom
I felt like there's so many [ __ ]
rules that I was constantly a guest in
my own house to the point where I'd
rather be at a friend's house because I
felt more comfortable there
what were some of the rules like like
what does that feel like it's you come
home from school okay or it's a weekend
because your mom worked yeah so um step
by step okay when you come home from
school you take off your shoes and like
a lot of what do you do with your shoes
a lot of them are little rules that
don't matter as much until it all starts
building I see that's what I was about
yeah so you take off your shoes very
normal a lot of Asians do that you put
them away but what do you put them away
like very normal just like in like a
shoe rack or something oh so there's a
specific because like walking inside
your house kicking your shoes off is
different than like taking your shoes
off let me build momentum I'll build
momentum and you'll see the ones that
actually matter I'll shut the [ __ ] up
again please shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
son of a make me feel better though make
me feel safe in my own home you're so
[ __ ] lucky the cameras are on so I
would come home take on my shoes put it
in the place she wants me to put it with
a specific place and you immediately
announce your presence like Mama or mama
or Mama whatever like Mom good morning
Mom good afternoon and you announce it
and if you don't she pretty much comes
out and goes what the [ __ ] was that you
greet her with a smile it doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] you have to do if you if
you had diarrhea you come you find where
she is at in the house address the
elders uh through seniority like grab
Grandpa how are you doing Grandma how
are you doing Mom how are you doing and
then you go do whatever you're gonna do
um so there's always that very specific
order of a greeting if there's guests
guests there then you address them
immediately and then you walk away and
then you get to go do whatever you
wanted so that's like step number one
step number two on a couch like like my
mom always says sitting has sitting form
standing at standing for him I can never
lean on one side
when you're standing you're standing
straight the [ __ ] up and down when
you're sitting you're sitting in the
straight [ __ ] up and down like what the
[ __ ] is this like if I sat like this
like what the [ __ ] is that
that's what men do you have big balls
put your [ __ ] feet down and be like
this
she's like sit sit like you want to sit
and it'll be like everything was like so
it felt like
almost like boot camp at home already
like I have like all these really crazy
rules even when I'm like eating rice I
can't just hold rice like with sloppy
hands the rice has to be like this it's
called Pearl and dragon's mouth so I
have to hold it a specific way I have to
eat like this I have to feed myself in
like 90 degree angles and then like no
wonder you're so good at math
everything's [ __ ] shaped since like
you were like two and [ __ ] I know and
then geometry algebra yeah and then like
I can never talk to my mom in a very
conversational way I think that probably
really destroys Rapport you know like
what was it like like I'll be like man
school's really hard today she's like
you talk to your mom like that I'm not
your friend first address me mother
and what was your problem
like that like you can't just have like
a heart to heart wow yeah everything's a
very like
um submit a request please like put that
in the suggestion box you can't even be
like man you guys this Coke's just
really good I'm like oh man thank you so
much we like we have a special recipe
for the Coca-Cola we make no none of
that it's like uh man it looks really
good it's like what about the beverages
do you like like it's like very like
that first address me as manager please
manager go ahead what was your opinion
so it's very like [ __ ] rigid
throughout even even when I'm sleeping
she goes you need to sleep like
Siddhartha so she made me sleep like
this every night on my right side
and you have to have your shots yeah
your hand tucked to your face and your
other hand on the side like this you
have to sleep like this does she sleep
like that yeah she sleeps like that too
so it's like literally from morning
until night it's like every single thing
has a form that you must do in that form
God so it just felt [ __ ]
uncomfortable and then of course you add
in the extracurricular activities
anybody that's ever had an Asian piano
teacher knows like it's not about how
good you play like how much emotion it's
the form you plan you know can you hold
a quarter on top of your hands while
you're playing
if not whack you know God Jesus yeah and
then so that's just like bare minimum
every day like uh yeah yeah conduct
and then comes the actual parenting so
you do something whack just with a stick
ah what the [ __ ] and then it's like she
just had sticks readily available tell
me what you did wrong I never even I
don't even know so I have to guess if I
guess wrong I get hit wrong so sometimes
I'll guess 10 times I get hit 10 times
I'm like was it because I was rude to
you then I put my shoes away or did I do
whatever or did I give you attitude or
you know or did I eat before you ate God
did I worry about you before I worry
about myself before I worried about you
you know it's like all like I just I
just keep guessing because I don't know
what the [ __ ] I did wrong so there's
always like this high alert like oh my
God oh my God oh my God you know
God Jesus so because of that oh I can't
breathe yeah it's not like I had like a
um a very strict supervisor that I lived
with
and any type of thing that I would ever
bring up either came with judgment or
conditions
what does a judgment sound like
um like hey like all my friends are like
dying their hair can I like dye my hair
why the [ __ ] would anybody want to do
that you want to be a [ __ ] hooligan
I'm sure that's pretty normal to a lot
of people you hear [ __ ] like that like
yeah yeah like oh I'm gonna shave my
legs boy you want to be a [ __ ] hoe
you know like there's that but then
there's also everything came with
conditions like
um
hey Mom can I uh you know all my friends
have like rollerblades now can I have
like can I get some rollerblades I could
go rollerblade with them I was like what
is it do you have a 4.0
4.0 why the [ __ ] are you even worried
about rollerblades
this episode of get close is brought to
you by betterhelp
you know as you guys know this year I've
been through some pretty tough times
because of my specific situations and
that's not unique to me a lot of people
are going through some tough times
whether this year or the last or the
last couple of years
and that's what I like about better
health because unfortunately life
doesn't come with a user manual so when
it's not working for you it's not
something you could just thumb through
some pages and find the solutions you
know and navigating any of life's
challenges can make you feel really
unsure whether it's a career change
new relationship a death in the family
or a new diagnosed sickness and a loved
one
and that's what therapists are here to
do they're trained to help you figure
out the cause of some of these
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy like the closest thing to a
guided tour for what's going on in your
brain because sometimes you're so in it
that you don't have time to analyze it
you know and you need a tour guide to
help like guide you through the left and
right and figure out what are all these
emotions and thoughts that you're
feeling and better help has connected
over three million people with licensed
therapists and it's super convenient and
accessible because it's a hundred
percent online and I'm a huge advocate
for therapy
because
we don't have all the answers you know
and for anyone that's kind of scared
about therapy they're not there to solve
your problems what they're there to do
is when you reveal your problems and the
emotions and your reactions to those
problems they help you discover and ask
questions so that your own solution is
revealed to you so they're not life
solution experts they are a tour guide
that help you to help you navigate and
hopefully ask the productive questions
to unlocking what you need to get to the
next step because for me I'm someone
that does not like to sit still and be
stuck in mud you know like I always want
to move forward no matter how crazy of a
life circumstance that's presented to me
and as the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable you just
have to fill out a brief questionnaire
to match with a therapist and if things
aren't clicking you can easily switch to
a new therapist anytime can be simpler
and there's no waiting room so if you
have like that weird stigma you're like
well this makes me feel uncomfortable
you have to worry about that you don't
have to worry about traffic there's no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com get
close that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash get close
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
you know and then you did have a manager
yeah you had a boss yeah so everything
was like Performance Based and
and uh so I never felt unconditional
love
[ __ ] [ __ ] no I for sure am spoiled
compared to you yeah
[ __ ] yeah okay and if I fell
she's like why the [ __ ] would you do
that to my son's body wow like there was
like before consoling me
you know like if I fell off the
skateboard I [ __ ] scraped my knee it
was like what the [ __ ] did I tell you
about being careful first before uh
consoling me this started when as far
back as you can remember
um
I don't have too many memories of when I
was like four
yeah probably
yeah five six seven on that air era fog
and [ __ ] so like Tiger's age yeah cause
most of my upbringing
in my early childhood is in one house so
I remember I started remembering it like
the managerial vibes from that house
damn dog and I mean like knowing your
mom now I understand where it comes from
single mom she had her pressure from her
parents I get all that
um so
how did you think living with her was
going to be because we've had this
conversation a lot throughout our
relationship
um because you're the only child and we
do every time we plan life we plan in
the immediate we plan in the one year we
plan in the 5 10 30 years down the line
so we're always kind of playing with
different scenarios
um and we've had the conversation in the
past where it's like well what do we do
when my mom wants to move in because
you're like that's for sure gonna like
gonna be her thing she's for sure gonna
want to you know that's like a lot of
Asian moms are like where's my place you
know like when you buy a house the first
thing she goes where's my room and I'm
like in the backyard where the dog lives
you know damn you still had her on the
property that's tight yeah no um yeah
for sure I think I
I
knew that that was something that was
coming but I didn't want to fulfill it
and why because I [ __ ] hate living
with her why because I felt like I can't
be myself even even as an adult like it
continues oh yeah it's [ __ ] like the
amount of control has so much residual
effects is pretty nuts I don't know if
you remember I'm sure you do I'll never
forget but even in my 20s when we're
shooting JK anytime I pull my pants down
I have red underwear because she wanted
me to wear red underwear so I'm not even
living with her but I'm still under her
control yeah I feel like Britney Spears
you know what I mean oh my God I feel so
bad for her I live in a [ __ ]
conservative ship I'm just kidding no
it's not that bad but um
but that's like the amount of control
that I have so I think like as I got
older and I wanted to get my independent
I mean I already started like trying to
run run away from home in high school
many times you know
so I think I felt like I needed to break
free to get my freedom and um
when I was able to first start getting
my own Taste of freedom I was like oh
yeah this is what I need this is what I
want but I would still get I mean even
on an earlier dates phone calls every
[ __ ] day and then it'd be like
multiple times we're eating at [ __ ]
BJ's or something oh [ __ ] my mom called
me wait a second and I walk outside and
we're like talking for an hour and
you're just there like twiddling your
thumbs like what the [ __ ] and that's
like every [ __ ] day in the middle of
a movie [ __ ] my mom's calling me and I
have to respond immediately go outside
talk to another album for some
[ __ ] [ __ ] so even as I got
old and became an adult I was really
trying to separate myself from that
control you know and even when you come
and visit she's putting uh like rules on
you oh where are those sandals oh do
this or do that you know yeah no that
doesn't fly and then even when like my
grandma was gonna pass away she was like
you gotta come I'm not even Buddhist
because you got to come to Taiwan and do
uh Buddhist service and you know [ __ ]
Buddhist service is [ __ ] a marathon
it's literally like five days long from
like normal though from 8 A.M to like 8
p.m at night that's reasonable like
that's reasonable because it's family
hold on 12 hour service sure on your
[ __ ] knees I don't know religion is
pretty nuts but the thought the thing
that threw me for a [ __ ] Loop where I
was like my [ __ ] from my the top of
my head just kind of like separated and
went whoa you know like that little
emoji that there's an explosion my mind
was blown when she was like Hey so my
parents are coming over but they're old
and I don't want them to travel on their
own I need you to jump on a flight pick
them up fly back with them and it was
literally like a 40 eight hour thing for
you where you get up I drive you to the
airport drop you off you get on a plane
you fly to Taiwan you pick up your
grandparents put literally the same day
that you just landed put them on a
flight fly back with them literally just
two days of your life gone because she
wanted you to do that and I was like
that to me is normal what like human
trafficking I'm down no you're don't
call it that don't call it the Ocean's
Eleven yeah but she wanted to be
attractive I'm trafficking my [ __ ]
are they not movements are my
grandparents not humans if you're not
trafficking [ __ ] what am I doing you're
being you're [ __ ] taking care of them
we went through LA Customs right you
were like their security there's traffic
in LA right shut up human and there's
traffic no with this whole Balenciaga
thingy that's [ __ ] popping and like
all this [ __ ] they're not kids drain
the swamp empty the swamp whatever the
[ __ ] I know but anyways my mom wanted me
to be in human trafficking I'm I love
crime I'm down shut up [ __ ] Ocean's
Eleven yeah but I thought that was crazy
to me that's normal I'm down for
anything you [ __ ] go on some like
girls trip into Mexico Oh [ __ ] getting
kidnapped you need to call me you need
[ __ ] Mike's Larry to come down I'll
[ __ ] come save your ass I'm down for
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] when it comes to
Mike Larry is that [ __ ] boy Bad Boys
yeah okay
God damn yeah what the [ __ ] are you
drinking all that coffee in your brain
[ __ ] slower than molasses all right
anyways I'm gonna kick you in the face
I'm gonna kick the mic the mic's gonna
Jam your [ __ ] teeth
[ __ ] up where I was
gonna [ __ ] right here I'm like yeah I
was there five minutes ago I [ __ ]
slow ass
hurry up you [ __ ] anyways what I was
gonna say is when it comes to religion
right when you when people do ceremonial
practices it's out of respect
right so like if um you're going through
the motions because I know you believe
in it so yeah Grandma passes away you
want me to go to the temple like some
incense you know [ __ ] bow a couple
times I'm super down
I'm not [ __ ] Buddhist just like how I
wouldn't you wouldn't drag me to some
crazy you wouldn't like drag me to go
get baptized right yeah like I'm I'm but
my mom dragged my ass to go do
a [ __ ] five day like 12 hour service
that none of her siblings are even doing
no she's the only like everyone is doing
the normal [ __ ] like I think there's a
is it called awake when the body's just
laying there
so the body's in the casket and you get
to spend time the whole week right and
so it's at the temple they booked a
little like their own uh I think it's
like a wee work but it's called we die
and then you put your own body in the
[ __ ] cubicle and you get to rent two
[ __ ] said we die yeah you're
playing cubicle and you went you rent
the we die and you get to it's by the
day and so the body's just laying there
it's in there to casket yeah it's like
that morning it's like part of the
morning
my it's already been embalmed so it's
not gonna rot or or whatever you know if
they already did the same thing
everybody does a normal [ __ ] come in the
morning if they have time bow bow bow
come at night when they have time so
most of the family I saw in the
beginning and that night if they had a
long work day and they can't you still
gotta attend to your family people are
dead anyways right people are paying
their respects my mom's the only one you
know my mom already my mama [ __ ]
chatting all [ __ ] day from
morning all the way till night the whole
time wasn't even eating Dragon my ass
too and I'm like I flew all the way to
America I mean from America for this
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're [ __ ] [ __ ]
walking around in squares and [ __ ] like
we're walking the yard and [ __ ] San
Quentin [ __ ] chanting [ __ ]
all [ __ ] day and I'm like bro I don't
even
believe in this [ __ ] but I'm doing it
for you but there's also so much control
that I don't feel like I have any other
way and the amount of how much you need
to respect and pay back to your elders
is so [ __ ] ingrained in me that um I
felt guilty for not doing it and then
there's what like
at least five other cousins that aren't
there why they live in Taiwan and
they're not even there I [ __ ] flew
all the way from America for this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know so it's just
even as I got older as an adult I still
felt like all this control that I had to
do so I just felt like I always felt
like wow like you know the like when I'm
around my mouth my mom I just [ __ ] my
[ __ ] neckties on okay so now I get
the picture completely suffocating
smothering controlling
um yeah like even when we used to like
eat it's like why are you eating like
all that meat you know I wanted
vegetarian oh still I mean she would do
that before but like she'll be oh like
uh or like not even just the meat
vegetarian thing but like oh there's so
much fried stuff you know like that's
that's too much heat like in Chinese
that's too much like heat energy so like
every single thing it's like a lot of
nitpicky stuff so I have all the basic
Asian nitpicky stuff and then I got the
other crazy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] crawling
around on my knees and stuff God
yeah so I just felt like oh man I think
this is love I don't know so at what
point what was like the pivotal moment
for you where you're like enough
the pivotal moment was the one time my
mom needed to pee really bad and I was
like you ain't coming in here big what
what
um what inspired that like what gave you
the courage to do that so
um
when I first moved out
you're hold 19. okay
my mom is an angel
which is a [ __ ] which is an angel she's
a [ __ ] angel what does that mean
this is uh just like you
so [ __ ] you why did you talking [ __ ] to
me so she's a [ __ ] Angel which means
like she's [ __ ] controlling as [ __ ]
but she wants not even the best she
wants more than the best for you so at
that time when I was 19 me and my dad
were getting into fights every [ __ ]
day at home [ __ ] Angels yeah me and my
dad are getting now I get it me and my
me and my dad are getting the fights
every [ __ ] day right I already had a
horrible
um academic life kicked out of three
four schools and all that [ __ ] finally
joined the Marine Corps First positive
thing I did graduated and got a
meritorious promotion I'm like cool got
some momentum get this new discipline
come back hit the books I'm going to
change my life around
but it's hard when you get into fights
every day because you're you know when
you get into a big I don't know if
you're like this but after I get into a
big ass fight I just want to knock out
because I'm like so [ __ ] exhausted
I'm so overwhelmed emotion and it's
fights over stupid [ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ]
it was really distracting me from my
studies and me and my dad didn't really
get along so I told my mom oh you guys
were fighting okay because you moved in
with your pops at that point yeah after
the Marines moved them with you and my
dad got it and you guys have such a
turbulent relationship you guys are
fighting literally every day over the
stupidest [ __ ] yeah and because you just
don't understand your emotions or know
how to control them you're completely
[ __ ] drained yes got it that's
something I need to [ __ ] move out and
um at that time I had the GI bill I
think it was like 500 bucks 800 bucks a
month I'm like that covers rent that's
pretty cool I'll find a job for the rest
and uh we'll be good to go and
um my mom being the [ __ ] Angel
she's uh a [ __ ] so you're Consulting
with her the whole time yeah you're
telling her I'm talking I'm talking to
her and uh she was like you go and run
behind mom's skirt that's what you did
no I did it oh okay yeah
that's true
we'll talk about this later
um so she
she's like you know I support you I'm
okay cool that's the angel part yeah
that that's cool now the [ __ ] part
which is also still has a little bit of
angel in it she comes back like a week
later she goes I have a plan
and I was like what's the plan she goes
I'm gonna buy another house
I'll buy another house you and your
roommate who is also a Marine
since you guys have to rent and both of
you guys have GI bill which is very
steady you guys could pay for that part
of the mortgage and if you guys stay
there for 10 years then the house will
slowly already start paying itself off
should you guys are going to stay there
for 10 years that's so cute so she has a
uh and if we if we leave we'll rent it
out you know and so it's
logically
it's like dude that's [ __ ] genius and
thank you for setting the whole like our
whole family up for the future
but the part that was like controlling
yeah was
I just want to do things on my own terms
you know what I mean if you wanted to
solve your own problems but she would
never let you solve it yeah yeah it's
literally like my way I know better than
you I'm Gonna Keep you keep here like
but essentially she's just protecting
you honestly yeah yeah about this whole
thing and uh by getting my front instead
of getting my back
yeah it's like I get you and you're also
amazed but you feel like an additional
layer of like yo I should fend for
myself yeah it's like uh you know what I
just want some uh
I wanna uh vanilla latte from Starbucks
and someone brings you like a 12 like
really expensive coffee
and it almost feels like why no better
you don't want that [ __ ] yeah yeah you
know like well I kind of just wanted
that you know I kind of just wanted
McDonald's thank you for this 12 Burger
but I just kind of wanted McDonald's
yeah why are you being so ungrateful
yeah so it's kind of like that so yeah
so I was able to leave
at and I went to go um did you protest
that at all were you like no I don't
need it I want to do it on my own or you
don't even know how to talk back I don't
know how to talk back I don't know how
to even sort through my own emotions
because I think that's a skill you have
to develop so you know when something I
was brought up so logically that as soon
as something makes logical sense I have
to force my emotions to support it you
know so I'm like wait that makes sense
so if I pay with my GI Bill my buddy
pays with his GI Bill we cover the rent
and if we stay here then my mom pluses
down payment and then yeah in 10 years
the house would be like this much paid
off we could refinance and then I'm like
yeah that makes sense yeah but you just
have this feeling but you don't even
know what it is yeah whatever oh okay
now okay you're not gonna have this
feeling because then I'm like but it
doesn't feel like you know like feelings
don't really come with full words right
so he's just like I don't know if that's
if I'm if that's the liberating feeling
because I kind of feel like if I put up
a piece of art I'm gonna get critiqued
on it if I do whatever I'm gonna get
critiqued on it I kind of feel like my
mom's gonna stop by any time you know
you just have all these but you don't
have the words for it you're just like
okay logically that makes a lot of sense
oh okay I'll do it yeah and then it's
not when it happens then you're like oh
[ __ ] the control's still here my mom's
coming every week and now she's like
coming in and like telling my friends
like oh why why is your room so messy
really yeah and I'm like uh if someone
was renting like you would never show up
you would never even show up and you
can't just comment on people's [ __ ] you
know and she's still at the cage or just
come in whenever she wants so even
though I moved out and I don't see my
mom every day I still felt that Weekly
control right and then you add that with
the amount of like in your ear my whole
life I'm walking around the house with
the in my ear
right and then my mom believes in
[ __ ] like good luck and all that [ __ ]
so she may wear red underwear so I pull
out my drawer I remember all red
underwear so I still have a lot of
control my mom believes in feng shui so
after we after we bought the house she
would remodel the door to face another
Direction so that's another reminder
that my mom's there and then she would
put like oh no but this feng shui is not
gonna hang a mirror over here so there's
just all these little
things even though I moved out her
control was still there so it wasn't
until uh when I moved in with you even
in uh UCLA you felt control
yeah what yeah I mean she didn't come
out as much because the [ __ ] 405 is a
[ __ ] so it's really good defense yeah
but still like it's like it's like
you're a [ __ ] strategy for war you're
like okay this is like a little moat I
know she don't want to be driving
through no 405 you know nobody does
nobody does so so I know that's that's
that was key and so she stopped by very
little actually you know what at UCLA
I felt quite liberated but I don't think
I can fully enjoy it because the studies
were so hard I see got it you know
because that's really switched one
anxiety for another yeah that's like
especially when you're like pre-med that
weighs so heavy like every minute of
your time you feel like am I wasting it
right now
yeah got it and then of course there's
still the did you call me today did you
call me today so you still gotta [ __ ]
do all that [ __ ] you know so it
wasn't until I moved in with you when I
graduated and all that and then this is
probably when I was like 25 now
I'm moving with you and you have your
own landlord your own set of roommates
that when I was living with you I'm like
cool she can't just come up in this
[ __ ] she doesn't [ __ ] own anything I
don't owe her anything I'm paying for my
own rent now
you know everything is uh super separate
super separate now and then there's that
one time where because my mom will
always be in the neighborhood where
she's doing well I don't know what
they're getting her back cracked or some
[ __ ] and this time she's in the
neighborhood I need to pee can I use the
bathroom and I was like you know what no
you cannot go back to the restaurant you
were just that if you need to go pee and
I really put my foot down there where
did you um start feeling it though like
where did you start going wait a minute
there's a lot of control Happening Here
was it when you moved and you finally
had a you were like oh [ __ ] this is what
it feels like when I was five oh and I
couldn't do any of the things that my
homies did yeah because you were saying
in 19 like when you got the house to
move out from your dad's place you just
didn't know how to recognize that
feeling so that's what I'm talking about
like what did you how did you recognize
that now was it because you moved and
you're like oh this is what it's
supposed to feel like
um I think college a little bit oh I see
that makes sense yeah yeah because she
couldn't control any of it yeah College
a little bit and to be honest
even a boot camp a little bit I think
boot camp like you were like this is so
easy the discipline part was pretty easy
the physical activity part is hard
because you know you're just like it's
like yeah they're pushing it's like yeah
it's like playing a sport but the whole
day
um but the discipline part like standing
like still for like an hour I'm like bro
that's [ __ ] that's what I gotta do at
home anyways you know that stuff's easy
but the fact that I can like
their rules are actually easier than my
mom's rules because I don't have to
sleep like this I can pass out you know
I could do whatever so I actually
enjoyed that environment even more
because it was a strict environment that
had um
more freedom you know why old
yeah [ __ ] crazy because it would be
like yeah you shave your head yeah you
gotta tuck in your shirt you gotta like
have it pressed everywhere right where's
the right uniform
but they're controlling you so you can
look like a [ __ ] stud yeah right
versus my mom
controls my clothes and my haircut so I
can look like a [ __ ]
in her eyes it was a stud also no so
it's [ __ ] way different I'm like I
don't mind if I like have to join a gang
and we all got to get the same tattoos
because at least I look dope whatever
her control was I came out like a [ __ ]
so I don't want to [ __ ] I don't want
to do all that yeah
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by the one and only manscapes and
what I have in my hand is the lawnmower
4.0 which I use religiously every week
to keep myself nice and trimmed and
presentable and ready to make taika's
brother or sister you know what I'm
saying and that's what I love about
manscape because they have a whole
plethora of options to keep the dude
let's face it dudes are kind of nasty
more appealing to ourselves and our
significant others and if you guys are
looking for gift ideas this is perfect
because they have a ton of stocking
stuffers so for example like the
Platinum package 4.0 comes loads of
little presents perfect for stocking
stuffers like a handful of their liquid
formulations shampoos body washes
upstairs and downstairs deodorants gels
exfoliants their shears 2.0 is their
full kit for Nail Care which I also use
has scissors Clippers tweezers if you're
ever traveling and you need to keep your
grooming under control boom nice easy
package throw in your backpack and
you're ready to go you don't have to
worry about throwing out your crazy nose
hairs or you have like cat like
fingernails or anything like that also
they have the persevere cologne which is
a light Breezy woodsy feel gives that
fresh tree scent even after the holidays
are over because you always want to
smell fresh and they also have a body
buffer which you can use to scrub your
skin and right now if you use the code
get close you get 20 off at checkout
plus free shipping and we all know with
the increase of gas prices how much
shipping can be so make sure you use
that code get close to get 20 percent
off plus free shipping to buy yourself a
gift or a gift for someone else
manscaped
okay get it
um understand the relationship so now
fast forward to you know your your papa
you know unfortunately taking his own
life causing all sorts of like shifts
and changes and weight to the situation
and the Dynamics and stuff and now your
mom's kind of left
basically starting from scratch you know
because she had her retirement plan set
your dad comes rocks all that [ __ ] up
for her we feel the effects she's
absolutely uh distraught and traumatized
by the whole thing because it did
unfortunately happen in her house
um so obviously when we feel that you
know type of world shakery we lean on
those that we trust and for most of us
it's our family so when she started
leaning in to us because you're all
you're her son you're the only one she
has and the rest of her family yeah the
rest of her family's in Taiwan but
they're siblings so her parents passed
and those that those were her rocks so
now you're her new rock she's leaning in
she's completely distraught traumatized
sad can't even stay in her own place
um she's dropping hints like hey man I
can't I can't be here how are you
feeling are you like [ __ ] what I feel
Mom first whoops
um all of the past history does not
matter nah my first was like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
really have like my first I don't know
five ten years of freedom
and I'm like
[ __ ] it felt honestly like you had two
years of Freedom yeah the pandemic was a
blessing yeah that's what it felt like
yeah honestly when the pandemic hit and
then my mom's like [ __ ] I'm stuck in
Taiwan I can't come back I'm like oh no
no not stuck like that I mean she's with
her family and then that's her hometown
she's born and they like um they're good
they have like
between two people they have like four
houses yeah so they're comfy and then so
that actually made me feel good because
I think that was the huge breath of
fresh air that I needed in my life
because I never really even got it you
know yeah that was the first time I
heard you say you were I think we were
driving you're like
I have this weird feeling
I think I kind of missed my mom and I
was like
I think up until the Porsche
every single car has been blessed by my
mom no remember I would get the Tahoe
and my Mom would [ __ ] like my mom's
we gotta do this I'm like I don't want
no [ __ ] monks around my [ __ ] car
he goes you gotta do this so she [ __ ]
hired these monks and they're [ __ ]
blessing my car with [ __ ] incense and
[ __ ] and I'm like man like every part of
my life has some sort of taint to it and
it wasn't really until like you know I
was like man [ __ ] this [ __ ] and I put my
foot down and I was like grabbing my
Independence back so it's actually still
quite recent you know like her [ __ ]
talents have been in me
um
I mean even at our wedding for decades
which is what like 2015 yeah that's like
seven years ago even at our wedding she
had like Talons still there you know
yeah so it just felt like I should be
like oh no no you need to do this and
then go go to like Joe oh no you need to
do this all you need to do I'm like
[ __ ] this is a [ __ ] American Wedding
we have our own Customs you see none of
us are wearing shoes in this [ __ ] we're
doing our own rules okay so what even
American traditions we're throwing out
the window all Traditions we're doing
this the way we want to yeah and she's
still going around like oh no no your
best friend the best friend gotta do
this with that person that person do
this this person you know so like it's
still recent and then so when the
pandemic hit I was like
the pandemic hit
I felt the two for sure yeah so
pandemic's very recent the minute this
all happened I'm like but no oh no you
felt like he was gonna go back to the
old ways yeah and then now how am I
supposed to say no you can't because
this is [ __ ] extenuating
circumstances
there's like there's no there's you have
to say yes yeah how do you say no you're
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but what was
[ __ ] cool is uh my wife is [ __ ]
amazing she is very supportive she's
loving and so my wife told me she was
like hey don't make a [ __ ] cry okay
don't even talk about it like that keep
talking [ __ ] I can't take this soft [ __ ]
he's telling me a [ __ ] I'm talking
about my wife don't talk about you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] angel
so my wife was like you know like um
your mom really needs you right now what
happened is really really crazy
and um she doesn't have anyone else
so if if she wants like she'd come stay
with us and I was like
oh [ __ ] you know I was like [ __ ]
someone's gonna go through this together
with me and not only do it's obviously
it's easy to see people's flaws so not
only does
my wife know the flaws because you've
been with me the whole time I've been
venting my whole our whole [ __ ]
relationship shut your [ __ ] mouth
shut my mouth about it and uh I built a
[ __ ] career talking [ __ ] about it
and um you
were able to accept her
so I was like if she's able to accept
her that's what I'm worried about
because I've been dealing with this I
feel like it's easier for me for someone
that hasn't grown up in a [ __ ]
Britney Spears conservative ship it's
gonna be really hard it's gonna be very
um like juxtaposing you know and uh when
you were down I was like all right let's
give it a try
and she's been [ __ ] Pleasant actually
which is pretty [ __ ] crazy yeah
because even when uh you know when the
incident happened when my dad just
passed and I immediately like went to go
to my mom
it was like kind of like PTSD I was like
[ __ ] here we go again I was all sleep in
my room please see my room and then she
got a [ __ ] rock hard ass bed and then
she wants me to do this and then do that
and then she goes I'll drink like cold
water I drink cold water it's too cold
like you get extra warm water and I'm
like oh [ __ ] here it all goes again you
know
um so
I got another taste of it but I don't
really give a [ __ ] about this I'm here
for you so I'll just deal with this for
a week
um but I want you to feel supported and
then so when I when I left and then
you're like maybe you should have your
mom come and stay and then get all the
energy of the house
uh I was like really really appreciative
oh cool I thought you were gonna be like
oh no trauma
I mean I was appreciated I just knew
what we had to do but I was also
counting on the days to kick her ass out
yeah yeah so I was like how long do you
think she'd be here and you were like I
can only I was out stand there for a
week yeah I was like no one in the week
I was like after a [ __ ] we didn't get
her ass out of here but what's crazy is
just been here what like two weeks three
weeks now three weeks see it was pretty
cool like I don't I don't have the urge
to want to kick her ass out yeah it
seems like now she understands so for me
it was always so eye-opening because I
grew up where the man is the head of the
household and that's how my you know
that's my dad's role my mom respected
that role you know they had their very
specific unique roles you know in their
Dynamic and then that's how he was
raising my brother
you know and like I always heard that
like like my brother versus like me and
my sisters had different sets of rules
that's how uh mine was too except when
the mom is Cersei Lannister
she doesn't want to let Joffrey yeah
Blossom yeah well that's what I'm saying
so when I saw your guys's Dynamic and
all my friends were Mexican too you know
and like I grew up predominantly like
with like Asians and Mexicans you know
and like all of our Mexican Traditions
or Customs or whatever were similar so
then I I'm with you and we're about to
start dating or we just started dating
and you're like talking on the phone all
the time with your mom I'm like holy
[ __ ] and you're 20 what this is crazy
and then now we're like living together
and like your mom's like making you wear
red underwear and like all I have to do
is because of my mom and I was just like
does she not know you're a man like I
just couldn't my mind couldn't
understand that because I'm like
what did like what type of what type of
man does she think she's raising you
know what I mean like because for me the
man has to take care of the family but
if the mom's always involved he's not
really a man he's just listening to the
mom's rules yeah so now what happens
when the mom passes away or is no longer
in the picture
is this man going to be able to support
me and my family and not support
financially but I mean just in every
aspect of the word support can it be
like a pillar if you've been the leaner
exactly so I was like I don't know if I
want to be with this guy because I kind
of I don't know how what other word to
use other than this one but like I was
just like man he's kind of like being a
little [ __ ] you know in the beginning
um obviously the more I got to know you
I'm like that's not the case at all but
it was definitely something I had to
heavily consider because I'm like
dude this is not this is not the man I
want you know like I want a [ __ ] man
that like the house could be mom around
his [ __ ] nut slaps his mom around but
understands what his role in his
position is because that's just what I
know a man to be yeah you know if some
shit's all [ __ ] crazy the house is on
fire the man needs to be in control have
a plan where the wife is now going cool
I've had like my plan I'm taking care of
like you know the roles like very
clear-cut rules yeah yeah
um so yeah seeing that relationship and
that control that your mom had over you
I was just like
I'm like man does she not like think
again because it's the way I was raised
but I'm like does she not think what's
gonna happen when she's not in the
picture no you know it's not how Asian
moms think
you know there's so much like that's
that's the part with like the whole
Asian culture and Asian love
it's one of the strongest
forms of love I've ever seen yeah and
that's undeniable and the actual most
materialized form of love I've ever seen
it's gnarly but it's also some of the
most Hollow
forms of love I've seen you know what I
mean I get you I get you like it's in
Balance it's Asian love it's imbalanced
it's like how do I set up my grandkids
how do I have a legacy generational
wealth and how do I make sure my entire
lineage all become Scholars and have
Prestige and
set up to be like a family to be
reckoned with
um so that's extreme love you know
but at the same time no one feels
supported so it feels kind of hollow
versus compared to the Western love like
everyone is all supported and like
loving and like kumbayaing but
everyone's a loser I mean that's not
true that's I mean from the Asian
perspective I see my mom would always
talk [ __ ] like I'm like like I'll be
like um oh look at him like they're so
good like look how good their
relationship is or whatever and then my
mom like
but he's they're just doing this or
they're just at Cerritos College
they're not at Harvard and I'm like oh I
guess if you compare it that way I was
like yeah I guess you know but then I'm
like it seems like he really likes his
dad though yeah I think
yeah but for them for them they're like
yeah but it's not I think we can't even
play piano like at the 10th level
you know I'm like oh I guess so I guess
I could play piano real good yeah yeah
but you're all crying in your room and
like oh yeah look at him like this guy
that guy still has a home loan I'm like
I guess you know yeah is this credit
score over 800.
you know so it's like it's like it's
different like that one it's like the
the love isn't as
that's something the love is a
materialize it doesn't feel as strong
but it's like packed it's compact it's
like it's from the core Asian is like
strong and like Legacy building but it
feels empty on the inside yeah
yeah
yeah it's gnarly I've never experienced
um support the way I have with your mom
you know and the more I understand her
and like
you know hearing how she was raised and
just the generation she comes from like
I understand where all of it comes from
and your mom's such a like go-getter and
such an extreme person
um that she wants to do everything at
the highest standard you know so her
version of a mom in her culture during
her generation is that right like what
are what is your community gonna think
about you like how do I support my son's
Sons you know
um how is he gonna be a member of this
community like all of that was was this
pressure that she had so like that's
already just Asian and then she just
like took it up even crazier because now
she had something more to prove because
she's a single mom and like you know she
just wants to be the best and wants you
to be the best so like
it's it's nuts I've never I've never
experienced anything like that yeah so
like
um you know when this whole thing
happened and like I was presented with
like okay how do I support my husband
and how do I support his family and like
I don't even see it as a difference
right like yes she's your mom but like
she's also mine you know like there's a
different relationship because she's not
my blood mom but like I definitely have
respect for her and stuff and like
anyone that's in your side of the family
is also mine so when that happened
anything I felt like about you know the
relationship I have with your mom or the
relationship I saw between you two like
I didn't care because it wasn't about me
at that point and it shouldn't be about
me right so for me I was looking at it
like okay now we gotta [ __ ] Voltron
this [ __ ] let's [ __ ] Transformer
this [ __ ] like how do we how do we
support you know our our weak side of
this family and that was the only thing
I could think of you know like let's
let's bring her in so everything that
any reservation or anything I had in my
my heart for that like
you know how she treated you growing up
and like all that stuff that I just
didn't agree with and I didn't like it
didn't matter because I'm like okay you
know our family member needs our help so
let's just let's come through so if you
were okay with it and you experienced it
I'm like what the [ __ ] do I have to
complain about like I shouldn't be
complaining about [ __ ] because I only
got a sliver of your mom and I get a
very polished version of your mom
because she's not my mom yeah yeah you
know yeah she also doesn't have the
Decades of I've been controlling this
person so it's so comfortable for me to
just
like put these other customers well and
I have the choice to be like I don't
want to listen to that yeah I can resist
and I don't really give a [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know uh but I'm obviously respectful
but like she knows she could only she
could only put so much pressure on me
yeah right because I'm not she's on my
mom yeah
um so seeing how you were good with it I
was just like yeah I was only good with
it because you were good with it oh well
fine but yeah if I was just following
your lead and then just like amplifying
I couldn't wait to throw you under the
bus I'm gonna be like oh yeah she
doesn't want you here
so I was like I was already ready for
that so I was like hey do you want my
mom here I would never actually needs it
actually I was like oh [ __ ]
I was like hey mom um
so I wanted to say that she doesn't want
you here but she does want you here yes
I really wanted to amplify that yeah you
know um and I'm and I'm glad we were
both very open to it and I'm so glad
that whatever your mom's been working on
in terms of herself and her
relationships it seems like she's doing
some deep [ __ ] Shadow work it really
does feel like that I don't know who
she's talking to or who she's
surrounding herself with but it's very
Progressive just talking in the backyard
she's just working out but dude someone
her age her generation her culture her
Traditions how like extreme she is for
her to look within and be like okay I
gotta do some of this keep evolving it's
nuts that's insane it's nuts I mean it
goes to show you again she's just trying
to do everything at the highest levels
which is so rad
um it's been very enjoyable having her
around like it feels like I have my mom
around you know I know the craziest
moment was when I was talking to you I'm
like damn it's been a while
and then I'm like like when do you want
my mom to leave or like when do you
think it would be and you're like
actually I don't even mind if she
doesn't and I was like what I didn't say
she doesn't I said I think it'd be cool
to have her we definitely need to
continue to strengthen our bond in our
relationship you know we're still a very
young couple yeah so we it's it's just
different having an older person or even
another person non-family around yeah
it's just very it just changes the
Dynamics so much because you're not
bonding this anymore there's additional
like even taika changes the whole day
very couple true like this is our time
you know
um but if it's not necessary I feel like
we don't need to stress ourselves over
it just yet yeah yeah so for sure I
didn't say she can stay here
indefinitely yeah if if we need to some
[ __ ] happens of course yeah someone else
diesel oh my God
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and obviously when she needs the help
and all of that of course but if it's
not necessary I prefer her live her life
instead of just being cooped up here
living under our schedules yeah yeah
true anyway so
um yeah just seeing that it's Christmas
time and and that it's you know New
Year's right around the corner and all
of that I'm just like yeah she just went
through some crazy [ __ ] you're her only
son she doesn't really have family
family so I'm like why would we send her
out all by herself you know
um and right now it's tight because she
has like different houses she likes to
visit like she has her home girl that
she sees as like her sister that she's
like I feel so warm there and I really
want to go back there because that's all
in California
she has her family out in Taiwan so for
her now she's seeing it as like so dope
I have so many home bases now where I
feel so much love yeah
um and it really warms my heart when she
feels very warm here because uh um I
don't know what her family structure was
like but I know
the this family structure she had with
your dad and you wasn't her ideal and I
know that's something that she really
regrets and she feels bad for yeah if it
almost feels like a lifelong regret
which sucks yeah so like because it
almost feels like um you know like the
old school thinking where you kind of
like you [ __ ] up once and you have the
Scarlet Letter for the rest of your life
it feels like my mom wears like this
like absolutely failed marriage and I
couldn't provide my son a happy home it
feels like this thing she's always
carrying around she really sucks ass
yeah it does so like my goal in in like
having her live here was to one show her
she's absolutely welcomed and like I
support her I love her you know like I
wanted her to feel that warmth for me
yeah and I also wanted her to feel the
dynamic of our you know our three-way
family because I feel like we have so
much love and joy and happiness just
between us two and then between the
three of us like me you and taika like I
feel like we radiate so much love and
happiness and just joy that I really
like I'm just so proud to show that to
people that I really wanted her to like
feel that and be like oh [ __ ] this is so
tight because one it makes her heart
feel warm that her son's in a good spot
right two it makes her heart feel warm
to just even be within that energy like
who wants to be in some tense energy you
know yeah so I really and and and and
the other one is
um she can rest easy knowing that you
know you're taking care of the family is
good we're set we're in a good spot like
if she's anything like my mom which she
feels like she is at times like Arch
they both live with high anxiety because
they just want the best for their kids
and they always want their kids you know
to be in a good spot so
um that was really my goal with like
having her be here to be like yo we're
all good and if you come in here you're
also going to be good like
um that's just always my goal with
people that I love like I just want them
to just
feel this like really big warmth
yeah I think she feels it because she
tells me she's closer to you than she is
to me yeah and I'm like that's good yeah
that's good get off my [ __ ] Casey
[ __ ] yeah yeah and some crazy
shit's been happening too between you
and your mom or you guys are getting
tighter but I think we should probably
save that for another another talk
because right now we've reached the end
of this one I don't care I know I was
just really trying to uncover all these
layers man yeah
how you feeling good good
you're not calling me a [ __ ] anymore I
win you [ __ ] you're always a [ __ ] in
my heart an angel [ __ ] say it right
which Angel [ __ ] comes first
[ __ ] Angel [ __ ] comes first I need to
[ __ ] make a shirt that says [ __ ]
Angel and then Angel [ __ ] what makes
someone an angel [ __ ] versus a [ __ ]
angel
um
I think Angel [ __ ] are um
I don't want to know I feel like you're
gonna [ __ ] make me feel so sad no
[ __ ] go ahead anyway all right on that
note [ __ ] you I love all of you guys
thank you so much for tuning in I hope
you were able to said shed some light
into your guys's relationship I feel
like the parent kid Dynamic is always
this weird one or it's like this like
murky one so
um really happy that we were able to
always open up and share
um yeah let us know your thoughts in the
comments let us know if there's anything
else you want to want us to tap into or
always an open book and sometimes we
forget the stories and the experiences
that we have so whenever you guys can
you know present any questions to us
um I really do enjoy it and I look
forward to it because I'm like oh yeah I
didn't realize I had that knowledge or
like I went through that so definitely
leave comments uh for us also like the
video share the video it lets us know
that you know we're doing a good job and
uh yeah we'll catch you next week see ya